happy glorious glorious friday everyone
so poor joe biden is in such deep
doo-doo not just his own
that the media seems to be turning their
back on him it's like when kilmead
enters a crowded elevator
they treat him like he's got monkey pox
from the source
and why well they finally figured it out
biden sucks harder than brian stelter
trying to drink a shamrock shake through
a crazy straw
so no one in the media is going to suck
up anymore they suddenly discovered
objectivity once he became objectively
the worst president of the past 100
years
although we're being told the president
has done everything he can
the president has done everything that
he can president is doing everything
that he can to make sure that we address
this issue we'll see we'll see what we
can do but i can't make any promises we
can build on what we've already done i
just want to make sure people also know
what we've done we don't have anything
to preview for you for tomorrow also
don't have an estimate for you and
haven't seen the numbers he is doing
everything that he can
to make sure that we take action and we
have been doing that 24 7. feel free to
reach out to me and we will do
everything that we can i don't have a
policy update on that but i know to tell
you now as i've been saying we are doing
everything that we can possibly we're
going to continue to do everything that
we can
i don't have anything to preview for you
at least she has a can-do attitude
as in can do nothing
it's not fair really it sucks to have
her job i'd rather be the maid who
changes amber heard sheets
this poor lady all she can do is say
we're doing all we can do
and suddenly you're in deep all you can
do do
it's a pun on poop
surprise surprised i'd hear that here
huh we never do we never do that
a new fox news poll shows just 18 say
the economy is excellent or good by the
way the margin of error for that poll is
plus or minus a hundred
percent
no one ever says that
no one ever says that plus or minus
three percent
you
that leaves 82 percent in agreement that
biden's economy is about as shaky as me
at a dry wedding
but i've said it before getting 82
percent of anyone to agree on anything
is tough although take a look at this
chart
yeah 82 percent think
i think i can kick roblox ass
and even more would pay to see it
wait wait really yes
you got to give the people what they
want rob remember i fight dirty
i'm looking forward to it behind the
dumpster
so poor joe's performance is so bad even
his staunches supporters are turning on
him i mean we know there are whispers
we know that there are whispers
and we we interview the president we
watch him in press conferences we watch
him do interviews on he was on jimmy
kimmel the other night and quite frankly
i had trouble following him
he was his answers are not succinct
right you don't want the president of
your party sitting at 40 or slightly
below 40
that's terrible like there's no other
way uh to cut it in democrats uh know
that when he does badly when he stumbles
you get nervous and you wonder is it
justice stutter is he tired or something
else there hmm keep up the good work joe
and you'll lose the 2024 nomination to
jimmy carter
so this might make you think there's a
media shift going on
but is it really and if it is what's the
real reason for it well when it comes to
mainstream media and their motivations
just picture rats swimming away from the
titanic
first there's financial incentive
ratings at other networks are plummeting
faster than joe's teeth in the bottom of
a glass at bedtime
especially cnns their numbers are
dropping faster than a hooker's blood
pressure after being rolled up in one of
hunter's old area rugs
i mean it's not true new riders as far
as we know a new rise not true and that
means you could be fired if you don't
get those ratings back up
see poor brian stelter his show is
hilariously titled reliable sources the
irony is as thick as his powdered
sugar-covered sausage fingers
why that was a compliment
it had its lowest rating in like three
years and according to sources stelter
is down to weeks if not days left at cnn
and that saddens me as you know when
chris cuomo was sacked i lost 57
of my content for my show
the remaining 43 was all stelter
and of that 43 85 was saturated fat
still
he was all he was my all-you-can-eat
buffet a place that offered second and
third helpings of comedic gold
so if he goes away what do i do
the news
hell no news is for suckers
take that bret bear
yeah
yeah we've got a special report for you
and it's about farts
and now you got cnn's new boss telling
his anchors to stop using the phrase big
lie to describe election fraud claims he
claims it sounds too much like white
house messaging as if that ever mattered
well it matters now when the guy you're
ripping off for content is as toxic as a
fentanyl filled fajita
i like alliteration so a lot of media
people are starting to drop their big
lies because they need to pay off that
mortgage for the house the second house
the soundproofed leather playroom
constructed under the floorboards
a shout out to don lemon
and as you just saw don really pivoted
going from always calling republicans
racist to now saying joe is nuts
we haven't seen a transformation like
that since bruce jenner went from her
hurdles to girdles
caitlyn will be on on monday so that's a
three-day tease
and i'm looking forward to it
so where does this lead
well in time will dawn be co-hosting a
show with sebastian gorka on newsmax
selling relief factor like it's popcorn
i don't know about you but i would watch
the hell out of that
gorka and lemon
sounds like something you order at uh
red lobster
but forgive me if i don't buy this
change of heart they know joe is done so
they're distancing themselves like he's
forgotten to wear pants and underpants
oh they still hate republicans they
still hate you and everything about you
they'll never care about regular people
with regular people problems like gas
rent or food but for now they're keeping
their powder dry only because hunter
might snort it
but also by being critical of joe now
they can then point to these paltry
examples as evidence of their
objectivity but it's only being done
because their back is up against the
wall and once they find their next
democrat to suck up to they will and if
he or she is just as bad as joe they'll
pretend just the opposite for as long as
they can or until they pay off the new
boat
tonight's guests
[Music]
she always brings energy
because she grew up without electricity
fox business anchor dagon mcdowell
he's the okie that liberals wanna chokey
gop u.s senate candidate from oklahoma
t.w shannon
and the first credit on his resume is
cheers and the second is did i mention
cheers
tv writer and producer rob long
and finally she's like a classic car
high maintenance and constantly breaking
down fox's contributor carter
[Applause]
rob
great to see you good to see you too i
you know i'm glad i could provide you a
little but i i would actually kick your
ass i don't think so i don't think you
got what it takes i think you got
you have the height disadvantage yes but
i want it more okay
well that matters yeah right right and
maybe i'll just take it how much uh do
you believe in this pivot do you think
that this is i want to focus on what the
media is doing right now why is it
temporary no look i feel like we often
think of the media as liberal and that
they are that but they are mostly just
partisan democrats and this is a way of
signaling to all the other democratic
politicians that if you jump in
we're ready to support you this is
really i really do believe this is code
and it's it's code to all the other
democrats sitting on the fence if you
jump in
we're not gonna tear you apart we're
looking for somebody to get behind the
first democrat that does that is gonna
get this incredible press uh tongue bath
i guarantee you i've seen this already
with people writing these columns about
it's time for the democrat celebrity
yeah absolutely two of those articles
right then so it's like that that's also
the code like it's okay if you come if
oprah if you decide to run right we've
talked about it but i i can't be her
running mate
dale just can't stand me it's just also
too there's too much sexual tension yes
there it is
we barely keep our hands off each other
we don't want that we don't want it
exactly degan always great to see you
sober i could take on both of you
i fight dirty
i go for the ears and then use my feet
on the other one
i would surrender
i bet you would do you think when when
cnn is telling their anchors to be less
partisan
uh do you buy this do you think this is
real or do you think this is more just
like a temporary thing until they find
someone new
um they need to get rid of anybody who
was giving jeff zucker a tongue bath all
day long every day so i think that's
part of that that's two uh two times
you've said tongue bath i think we only
have one more which i just did
so we're gone
like a cat yeah
um
i think that if biden can turn it around
the media will stick with him and i i
mean this he's clearly a
huffy fractious grandpappy but he needs
to use that
on the like on the white house stage all
he needs to do is start firing people
publicly and that kind of humiliation of
his own staff i think would bring along
a lot of like goodwill from the american
people even and people who work in media
just an example like have an event and
say i'm gonna my this event is gonna be
about bringing down gasoline prices and
then turn around and just
can jennifer granholm the energy
secretary
but right on this
just and
just right there because he's already
got it in them i'm sick of all the lies
and i hate your laugh
but you know i got to tell you that's
like expecting a rock you know to write
a beethoven symphony it's like there's
no like it's like oh because he's a
hollow he's i mean the reason why he's
so dangerous is there's nothing there i
think that he's an angry son of a [ __ ]
oh really so yeah and i think that if he
does this he could he has this in him i
think you all are way overthinking the
media there's one reason that the media
has pivoted like this and that's because
like the rest of us they miss donald
trump their ratings are in the tank uh
that's the truth
i will
i disagree in the sense that if they if
they really missed donald trump they
wouldn't keep pushing these hearings
because the hearings are designed to
keep them off the stage and to elevate
the democrats
no i disagree they're trying to keep
donald trump from from running again
that's the whole reason that they're
having these these hearings because when
you look at what the democrats are
rolling out as evidence of this this
alleged uh uh coup that supposedly
happened in the country the truth is
they're trying to paint republicans as
all being these evil insurrectionists
when not one person has been charged
with insurrection two federal treaty i
know i know i
i know i'm trying to get ahead but but
but again when you look at the media the
real reason that they're doing this they
don't want donald trump to run again and
they're pivoting from joe biden because
they know he's bad for ratings the media
has one they have one thing one thing
only and that's to control the people
and also to get ratings for their
stations and without donald trump they
don't have any it is amazing cat how
brazen the pivot's been in some of these
folks right it's like especially don
lemon like all of a sudden it's like
what happened to the old don lemon
remember him i was a nice fella i guess
i think to me
it's not that i don't know i think it
took too long yes because it's not like
all of a sudden joe biden got like this
yeah
right he's been like this the entire
time through the campaign
yeah i threw the campaign and i mean
when i was gone yesterday where i went
to go see paul mccartney right and it
was it was amazing
but it was he three hours okay he's
singing he's playing guitar he's playing
the ukulele he's playing the piano and
the entire time i'm thinking this man is
older than joe biden
who
yeah
who cannot stand for 15 minutes yes
what were the high points of the concert
i mean i i uh the whole thing yeah yes i
was sobbing tears of joy it was amazing
best night of my life no offense and you
were with me
and you were with your dad yeah even
better yeah there you go
well i hope they don't take stelter from
me i know i'm sorry that'll be really
hard for you yeah i don't know what's
gonna happen i hope there's some kind of
encounter group for that
i'll set one up all right you could hire
him yeah that's what i was thinking
he could be my andy richter we have him
standing way over there and he can't say
anything
that's who he's our andy richter but
i think better
you you have a little trap door here and
he and he's like the [ __ ] in pulp
fiction yes yes
oh that's even better yes
and it's weird because i have that
costume i know
all right
i know you know
[Laughter]
i use a lot of baby powder to get you
out of that
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else